President Joe Biden is proposing a boost
to Medicare funding Joe Biden's proposal
is that if you earn over four hundred
thousand dollars per year either in
wages or capital gains your Medicare
rate will go from 3.8 percent to five
percent this is expected to generate
about 110 117 additional billions of
dollars over the next 10 years or
roughly 11.7 billion per year will it
pass
almost certainly not this is part of
Biden's White House budget White House
budgets are political documents they are
not legislative documents it will be up
to the House of Representatives to
ultimately vote on how all of these
proposals that House of Representatives
is currently controlled by Republicans
but Joe Biden is sticking to his promise
of not increasing taxes on anyone making
under four hundred thousand dollars a
year